[Laughter]
this is the problem
[Laughter]
good luck
that's the most dangerous game hunting
humans with props
oh thank god hey he didn't use a prop he
used to bolt
uh a bolt is a prop no no it's a tool
block him in block him in
he's blocked wait guys hold on
okay wait a bridge i will shoot your
friend okay mark oh
what is happening prop hunt working as
intended see if i can get you guys
hi what's up [ __ ] hi
for free
oh god the camera wow
[Laughter]
i need to reload
no no no no no no no i can't do it you
don't know what i'm doing to you
i don't i don't know either ow
but i can just walk
oh
missed me
nerd
oh i was hoping to kill you for an
amazing comedic effect wait i got a i
got a bottle on my head uh
i'm fixed what does the rope do
nothing it looks and ropes
hey see how roped it is hey i'm gonna
put this baby on my head and you try to
shoot it okay okay
all right just try this
[Music]
okay so how do we get a problem working
i don't know um i'm sorry that that
happened i forgot what right clay did
with this gun i gotta be honest
we're gonna play we're gonna play uh
orb chicken you have to ricochet to try
to hit the other person okay okay okay
all right
you get first hit oh my god
[Laughter]
all right my shot
hang on i'm stuck in something
oh
no
you guys ready for this yeah it's like
that movie where you got to curve the
bullet
ow all right well
three is pretty good my hit
jesus yeah
i think it hit it hit tron and then
bounced off of him somehow directly at
me in a way that didn't make any sense
where did you go which gun is this it's
three three pull free twice okay then it
was it hold just breaks you have to
bounce it though you can't just shoot it
at me
dude
damn
bonus points for stylishness all right
wait i spawned here so i get to shoot
now you ready uh yeah yeah sure this
seems very fair
no i'm not gonna shoot it directly at
you don't worry
i believe you you have a bad feeling
[Laughter]
all right
this is my spot now it's your go i think
no it's your go oh my god all right all
right i'm gonna bounce it off and i'm
gonna take oh i'm gonna go stylish get
weighed first and then
i gotta crouch for this and then get bob
on the return trip am i allowed to play
defense
oh my god
what the hell
does it when it hits one of us does it
go directly to another one how it goes
straight through i think it just like
melts right through sean's your shot if
you want to take one okay i'll go down
here
oh
god active god still counts
i'm gonna try and just bounce it left to
right okay
you guys ready for this yeah i'm ready
it's going to be like 12 bounces before
i kill ollie is all at once okay i'm
ready
oh great oh great
almost almost almost two of three is not
bad it seems like the hitbox for that is
maybe pretty wide or i don't know
like we're hitting a lot of those
i don't know man
did you wait yeah wait
oh look at bob hiding in the door i'm
here i'm here i would have laughed it
was like right
that feels harder to do
yeah you're welcome
he was just really trying to kill me so
i was just like you know seeking you out
here's a hard mode i have to stay in
this room and shoot it out the door and
try and get you guys
interesting you're allowed hide anywhere
down in that hall
guys do we know what's going on with
this door what door
it's a magical door it's fine don't
worry about it oh here comes the ball
now
you heard me but then it went into the
other room oh it's because you have a
door no
i wasn't doing this where does this go
hang on hang on hang on it's messed up
hang on there you go there's your door
wow
hello thank you oh i can't get out
oh that's fine great door man well how
do we play prop hunt i don't want to
like spoil all the fun but uh can one of
you guys try to start it uh because
maybe maybe i'm doing something horribly
wrong yeah i could try to i'll try to
host and see what happens okay well
there's one video in the bag good job
guys
[Laughter]
go listen to distracted
why did you sound like a south park what
do you mean is
something didn't work right be fair wade
was always our starter anyway was that
true
you always kind of knew what was that
you play more multiplayer games than the
rest of us so you know how what's up
yeah you know what's up that's cause i'm
not talented enough to stand on my own
wow i don't know if you count what we do
talented but i'll take the compliment
we're welcome
i expect at least one of you be like nah
man you're great but you all just were
like yeah you're right very quickly
oh it's working lua started what's
working whoa
oh look at that i missed this map this
background
spectator it's like comma or period to
switch teams i think or something like
it's not working i'll just disconnect
and come back all right bye we'll have
to get through this round anyway
yeah we'll just kill
[Laughter]
what was that
[Music]
the taunt does anyone else hear that
how do you talk what's the button for it
i don't know i right click it must be
proximity based i'm spending autonomy
on which is something i can turn off but
right now we have auto taunting for
props oh i hear it
wait do that again i won't do that again
i don't know how to talk manually it's
just random to try and like
hone you in on people um is there a
button for taunting bob that you found
it used to be
f or something i think it was f3 like f3
yeah
but this is a different game mode so who
knows what it is it's it's f4
i hear that i just want one of them to
go it's morbid time
[Music]
pokemon
it's like new grounds taunts
all right shall we uh
it yeah let's just uh go for it kill us
whoa wow that's how i do
all right
very serious ultimate prop on time i'm a
propaganda wait i'm a prop as well what
oh three props 100 oh
oh god oh no
oh i'm being real sneaky
oh wait
i can't select hunter if i try and
change team
i it might just be like one to three
maybe there's only one hunter at a time
before where i could have uh messed with
it
you
idiot i can restart it because i think
being a lone hunter might be kind of
boring you did this
[Music]
oh you guys are shutting down i mean the
the auto taunt kind of does even it
though if you think about it
who's talking here if we're all taunting
at the same time it does not help
oh
wait
wait a minute it hurts
doesn't it oh
oh [ __ ] where'd you go
peekaboo
oh who how are you alive and i'm dead
you're garbage get out of here
why is that my taunt what was that mark
nothing spot john i'm very disappointed
in you i'm trying to get out that door
it didn't
is work automatically how do we get out
yeah it's all the way just run into it
it's not working
you're out of it now on my screen oh oh
this is your argument your rotation
face face face back once you came i
don't know how
and then hit r to lock your rotation
you face where you look
i am [ __ ] lagging like crazy oh
good enough
mark excellent spot thank you you're
never going to find you he will never no
absolutely not even though you're
talking
no no no
no it's not like you're off the map
it's not off the map but it might not be
in the area you think yeah maybe if you
were uh better at this you know all
those years that i've been practicing
since the last oh [ __ ] yeah
no that's not copyrighted
oh there's a whole other else oh they
changed this map okay are we making up
the rule where we have to move instead
of just standing still like well that's
the taunting is probably sufficient
there would be no maybe if it gets tight
at the end maybe move around but
okay you got a good spot you deserve you
know you deserve to win
oh okay
bobby you did
yeah he killed me super fast did that uh
that hurt mark
did what hurt hey are you thirsty are
you thirsty can i offer you a delicious
beverage
ignore the blood i just get on my knees
and take a sip from your go away
oh god go away
got shot
listen to what he says
i'll give you the count of five
one
two five
wait did you see anything out of the
ordinary
maybe something
[Music]
oh boy
you know what i'm happier i'm more more
proud of you now than i've ever i am
very proud of excellent work he'll he'll
never uh he'll be so thirsty after that
long hunt uh-huh
he uh he he doesn't have the legs to
find you it sounds like you're shooting
a lot of stuff that ain't me boy
i sure am
mostly just to
must be getting real
hungry
from all that shooting are you melons
no
hey what were you
i was a weed
i was one weed are you feeling high oh
now mark is the hunter i'm not nice i
think because i performed the best in
the last round oh c is taunt menu
tauntman oh guys i found i found the
cheap prop i found it
oh you can talk whenever you want when
you click c
oh my god i'm sold out
copyrighted uh sorry sorry
you you want me to give you some time or
uh i'm i completely lagged out i was
frozen for so long please sir all right
i'll look away i'll work spare me just
wait give me your id give me your id
what are you
okay here you go here you go all right
mr oh
god
[Music]
no one down here you say hmm
down there
here
down there where it where is anywhere
really when you think about it up
up oh yes oh the way to go is up
and if i were to just
listen
you won't find anything in three seconds
there's not a thing
[Laughter]
wait a minute hey
hey wait a minute
there we go
i did get him look if i move i desync
and just get stuck in place
what
what
you heard you what
what okay i'll fix it i'll find a good
one
am i getting warmer can you hear my
taunt no
did you hear my taunt no i did not
i'm in the wrong place oh i can't stop
it oh no how are you not hearing my
taunt i would hear you guys taunts
either right now
oh
you don't hear this
no
nope
oh god i played it twice
oh [ __ ] what in the hell is happening
what i could not it was from two
different places at once did you both
taunt yeah you talked to me like
constantly right now i did john cena
i think the taunt you heard was the auto
taunt that it does for both of them
i see oh you were close you were very
close apparently i was
it's very it's very beautiful
bob what are you doing
nothing
what are you doing bob hmm
i love smelling the fresh air
[Laughter]
i can't tell where that's coming
[Laughter]
from hmm yeah it echoes like throughout
the whole map that was suspicious
yeah it's tough to attract the taunt
sometimes that's why i didn't know where
sean was at all yeah that's the reason
not because of my expert hiding spot
or your misdirective uh delicious
you could have just eaten the pineapple
are you hungry for some
weed
okay i'm moving
oh my god i like out like crazy when i
touch stuff
where is is that coming from inside or
outside
[Laughter]
oh my god
uh huh all right okay
sad violin 2014. bob you've changed
nothing i thought you were oh damn it i
ran out of time ah where were you
i was in the room with the tables and
the banana you were literally looking
all up in my room oh the last one i just
went in ah damn it yeah
i was a
man i never have to hunt ever this is
the best game mode ever i'm hunting
again all right here i love this game
mode seems really fair oh yeah oh yeah
baby oh yeah just don't touch it
oh yes
that's not what i usually say during
oh yeah don't touch me just don't talk
about it don't touch it
don't touch it you don't touch it
don't even look at it you know what i
like
i don't know if the pro are their taunts
help at all well i want there's a whole
lot of them you are [ __ ] yeah you're
real
are you real
[Laughter]
what am i looking at
[Music]
dude
no listen hey you need me to hold
anything for you i can tell you where my
friends are that's a good bit we used to
do right now
oh
hang on can i become something that fits
through doorways
how do i become this fellow great okay
i'm a cohn
follow me i won't betray you i'm
following bob are you betraying us right
now no no mark i would never betray i'm
betraying wade right now ah
good good mark's definitely not in here
he's a radio
oh dude
do you not remember how to crouch to
look under the beds um hey bob you seem
to kill anyone bob you seem to have run
away during uh our uh teamwork i'm right
here i'm just a plant this is me hello
it's fine it's fine i didn't fail at
running away i did that on purpose
looking real good guys anyway i may have
had the wrong room yeah
although i might not know where they are
no
where are the snack masters i guess not
wait what does chris hansen always say
don't [ __ ] kids
what's the other thing he always says
probably yeah
why don't you have a seat over there i
don't i don't he says why don't you have
a seat oh you're a water cooler that's
what that's what chris henson says it's
the bottom of it there's a cooler yeah
gotcha you're a water cooler ain't you
don't [ __ ] kids and then eat like
spider-man's out of there
what uh what a cool taunt i just did
oh oh what a long taunt i am currently
doing oh warmer warmer warmer
warmer
warmer you ran past me like two minutes
ago
i just get rid of just shoot everything
there's no punishment for shooting
randomly is there do you not lose health
anymore no you do lose all the time yeah
yeah wait do you guys hear that sound
you have 30 seconds wade
you got me fair and square where are you
at buddy wait i'm i'm coming to i'm
coming
hey
trust your instincts here
i know where you all are
i
i don't play here hello yes hey i don't
believe you do
there you go you got 10 seconds to find
mark
find me
how even
you might need to dry your hands on the
paper towels that are in the bathroom
okay well that's a little specific
[Laughter]
oh you are never finding me
oh
i find you immediately i'm gonna laugh
me too
oh god oh no
okay oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] okay that works
whatever it is what it is this is
cheating this is 100 cheating
did you find us
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know what i think he's always there
i'm pretty sure he's always there oh
yeah that's normal that's normal we do
it we don't have the rules of you have
to be somewhere where you're like
visible right
do we i don't know i mean you have to be
seeable if you're literally in a place
where like no one can see you i see you
the thing weird about this map now is
they've added more rooms to it it's
different than i remember so like you
can hear people in places you don't
think you can go but there's other ways
around right
you're on the wrong side of history
right now bob
and history is a wall
he's world war one
just i can see the sunset reflected in
my glasses it's just beautiful
you're in the right area bob
okay okay good good he'll never find me
all military forces have been eliminated
i'll give you i'll give you a chance but
wait wait no go over to the doors isn't
this like awesome isn't this perfect
yeah you're pretty much invisible unless
i happen to look right at you actually
if i look at the sign
there's it's unexpected you're
distracted
oh wow
no
it was an awesome spot
good one mark thanks
thank you
[ __ ]
assuming trash can
with that
i tried really hard
i was standing in my restaurant for a
long time waiting for you
you know what mark yep oh you left your
spot
[Applause]
the screaming is really inconvenient
is i shot this bottle earlier i just
want to say that i know i know i was
thinking that you would like uh
not remember
he's reloading run
no no no no i i know i know how this
ends get him from distance like go back
to those boxes and try and get him i'll
hit you with a 360 no scope
come on it doesn't bode well
10 seconds oh that's too far hang on
this is a different sense than my valor
incense
edit that and cut the paws out okay yeah
like every other game i'll just be
hunter that seems good i haunted once
you could complain or you could uh shut
up
show
options
your
goddamn
well uh well versed out by you thank you
your intellect astounds me
it astounds us all
and it sounds most people oh can i oh
could i be a smelly boy
i don't know if i want to find you
i don't want to play anymore can i go
with not play
i'm tremble oh yeah
some classic
lines in this game now really
really harkening back to our youths
one of you beefy
no you're not exactly
what the hell is going on you're
shooting computer monitors calling us
beefy
yeah he's out here he's out here beefing
right now
that's the sound i make oh no
[Laughter]
flying around inside what's happening uh
making a mess can i turn myself into a
person while you were at this table
if you keep shooting i'm sure you'll
find us you miss all the shots you don't
take wade shoot everything i take a lot
of them
shoot everything
do it
oh this room is great
oh stop taunting me
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
oh uh i was in the taunt menu
[Laughter]
that's about what you deserve for that
time
[Laughter]
all right whoa what in the hell is going
on there
uh john what what yeah what is this i
don't know
i tried to like change the things it
wouldn't let me and then suddenly that
happened
what is this
whoa
whoa what did you do what's that i don't
know there's a purple ball on the ground
dude
random ammo
bob have you always been there yeah this
is i've been here the entire time no way
yep
how how and i've been counting the
entire time
just tell me you're very very very
stupid
[Laughter]
you literally walked on me
[Music]
okay
where
why am i stupid
wow
do you know where you found that purpley
thing
yeah
you literally stood on me oh that can't
be
wait
bob wait
bob
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay you're on the right floor
no no go back down
you shot the other one so many times oh
my god the other two but not you you
brought every computer on that counter
but not
i me i love the upgraded taunting system
it's so amazing yeah i hate myself so
much no
no
hey i a hunty now
pick good spots always and forever
why are you doing this to me get out of
here
let's go
let's go
let's go boys
how do i oh
anybody around here
[Laughter]
okay i'm lagging like crazy and you just
vanished so
cool
you technically got away
i earned that thank you how do i get
through doors oh god having some trouble
oh my god
anytime i get near an interactable
object i like rubber band
[Music]
it's the scariest muffin man monologue
it's
ever
it's happening
i feel like this should be your shining
moment if the mom get the camera mean
oh god you're damn ugly i'm stuck in
everything
you damn
you call me ugly no
[ __ ] up
ooh lo-fi vitas
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
listen
i am food related okay and i'm on the
main floor come on now i'm also on the
main floor
i'm i'm
it takes me like eight seconds to go
through a door so even your kids can do
laundry even your kids can do laundry
is that like outside the wall or am i
right next to you
uh i am inside
the taunts are coming from inside the
house
you just put your own uh your stinger
that you made mark you could just have i
turned around
okay i'm just gonna say every time i
open a door my whole game freezes for
like 10 seconds someone's on the stairs
someone just came down the stairs and
went into the bedroom it wouldn't matter
just keep teleporting
someone's
in the hallway right next to you wait
okay on your screen what just happened
right over your face
because i went in and out of that door
twice come to the kitchen are you like
huh
what why am i not taking damage
i don't know great question
that took forever i had 200 health i
don't know how i had so much health you
get more health the bigger the prop you
are uh
god mark are you the water cooler no
he's dead it doesn't it doesn't
yeah you i lost no shoes oh
are we going for boys i want office oh
dude okay what's ph offense versus cs
office uh uh oh that's an interesting
point i don't know well we'll find out
[Music]
you